hello the U.N Secretary General is
urging the Israeli government to stop
its decision to speed up the
construction of illegal settlements in
the occupied West Bank a spokesman for
Antonio Gutierrez said in a statement
the Secretary General is alarmed by the
anticipated advancement next week of
over 4 000 settlement units he
reiterated that settlements are a
flagrant violation of international law
he urged the Israeli government to Halt
and reverse these decisions and to
immediately and completely cease all
settlement activities in the occupied
Palestinian territory Khalid is a senior
fellow with the Middle East Institute
and he says Israel's decisions on the
illegal settlements undermines the hopes
for a two-state solution
the the actions of this Israeli
government have accelerated virtually
every negative Trend that you can
imagine from the violence on the ground
to settlement expansion to evictions to
building and uh you know expanding
settlements in the so-called doomsday
settlements like E1 uh outside of
Jerusalem so uh this is really it I mean
an attempt to uh to slow down uh this
very accelerated Pace at which this
extreme this government is working to to
destroy chances for whatever may be left
of a two-state solution I I think unless
the uh very strong words are combined
with some sort of action by key players
like the United States or the European
Union uh some sort of uh consequence to
these actions
um then they're simply going to be
ignored as they always have been uh so
there really needs to be action on the
ground uh to to back up these strong
words and we just haven't seen that at
all we have two correspondents joining
us in a moment we'll cross over to Nida
Ibrahim in the occupied West Bank to
give us an update on the situation there
but let's bring in Imran Khan who's
joining us first from West Jerusalem
Imran to tell us whether there's been
any reaction from officials where you
are to the comments that have been made
by Antonio Gutierrez
well there's been no official comment on
those a particular comments from Antonio
Gutierrez in fact the only comments
about the Janine raid came last night on
Monday evening when prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu visited some of the
Israeli soldiers who were injured in
that raid and he just reiterated what
we've heard him say before that they're
still committed to fighting terrorists
as he calls them anywhere that they
might be in the occupied West Bank
however what I'm seeing what we're
reading in local media is that the Army
in particular is conducting quite a
serious post-mortem of the operation
about what happened particularly into
the use of these improvised explosive
devices that managed to disable a
military vehicle and that's what led to
those helicopter gunships firing Rockets
into missiles rather into the Janine
refugee camp and that's the first time
we've seen anything like that in 20
years there may well be reaction to this
uh this new settlement building that
Antonio Gutierrez was talking about some
4 000 new units May well be approved
very soon but right now there's no
particular reaction to that and it's
likely that we aren't going to hear any
reaction official reaction at least
um to the Janine refugee camp raid yeah
okay Imran we'll cross over to Nada in a
moment and find out exactly what
happened during that raid and the
resistance that was put up by the
Palestinians but while I have you with
us let me just keep with what we've been
hearing from the U.N these statements by
the UN Imran do they actually change the
reality on the ground I mean there's
really government judging by past
history we'll still go ahead with its
plans
that's absolutely right if any un
decision has been made that goes against
Israel it almost immediately comes under
criticism from the Israeli government
particularly uh right now with this
far-right Israeli government uh that has
a agenda to try and push forward uh
settlement building and remember the law
around settlement building actually
changed a couple of days ago in the
occupied West Bank there used to be this
six phase process where politicians
could actually raise objections that's
been got rid of and now there's one man
and betzel smotrich who has almost total
control over approving uh brand new
settlements in the occupied West Bank
they've streamlined the process that's
the word uh word the Israelis are
actually using but this is alarming to
both the International Community and
it's things like that that have got
Antonio Gutierrez worried and that's why
he made those comments but will they be
listened to by the Israeli government
well they haven't in the past so it's
unlikely they'll do so now okay thank
you so much Imran Khan reporting for us
from West
was just saying that what they're
reading in the media over there is that
there's going to be a postmortem that's
going to be conducted as to what exactly
happened in Janine because Israel did
launch that assault but they were in for
a big surprise by the resistance that
was put up by Palestinian Fighters
indeed there is a different reaction in
Janine it is of Pride Palestinians say
that the resistance there although it
has very primitive weapons it has very
or really no training whatsoever so they
were able to kind of incur damage when
it comes to the Israeli forces that have
been raiding Janine for the past year
and even more than that basically Israel
says that it wants to crack down on the
resistance and the fighting groups that
have been really growing Engineering in
nablas we're seeing them also growing in
other uh Palestinian cities like Jericho
so for them it's important to keep
reading and people that are afraid that
Israel is going to be going towards a
full-on military operation to crack down
on the Palestinians there but as far as
they're concerned they say that they're
sad that they've lost many Palestinians
during these raids but at least they
were telling us that they were resisting
the Israeli occupation a sixth
Palestinian has succumbed to his wounds
this morning after he was shot during
the raid it raises the number of those
who were killed to six remember this is
a very close-knit
refugee camp very heavily dense the
father according to journalists who were
there the man who was killed is a father
of another Palestinian who succumbed to
his wounds earlier this year in another
Israeli raid journalists were telling us
that he was surrounded he couldn't get
the medical care needed so he succumbed
to his wounds we were there in Janine
and we prepared this report for you have
a look
this is the moment that turned and
Israeli arrest rate into a 10-hour
gunfight
inian homemade explosives damaging
armored vehicles in the Janine refugee
camp and injuring eight Israeli soldiers
it took Israeli forces nearly one hour
to move the soldiers to hospitals and
hours more to pull out at least five
vehicles
as the camp felt like a battlefield
the Army was in the houses of my
neighbor and my father an Israeli
military jeep was near my car here you
can see the damage they were lined up in
the street it was very scary
it's become common for Israeli raids to
leave behind Palestinian casualties but
it's rare for Israeli forces this is the
first time in nearly 20 years that we
see Israeli helicopters strike
Palestinian targets here in the occupied
West Bank people here say that scenes
today resemble the battle that took
place in the refugee camp in 2002.
shortly after the Israeli forces
withdrew Palestinians buried they're
dead
among the five Palestinians killed is 15
year old Ahmed
anytime I asked him for something he
always said yes he was decent polite
respectful but his problem was that the
moment the Israeli Army raided he ran
towards them he wanted to die after his
friend omo was killed the death of his
friend was very painful for him
is fighting against Israeli forces on
Military
they're the ones attacking us if they
didn't come over none of this would have
happened
snipers are targeting us journalists
shot this video from one of the rooftops
near the camp
cameraman has a monster was shot in the
side while wearing his prescription
they shot me four to five times and even
as I was rushing to the ambulance they
kept shooting at me
Israeli forces have been raiding Janine
and nablis for more than a year now they
say it's to crack down on fighting
groups
but many Palestinians say they're proud
that the limited weapons can put up such
resistance against one of the most
advanced armies in the world
the occupied West Bank